on this final day of pride month last
day of june already and almost 10 years
after the repeal of don't ask don't tell
we're taking a closer look at the
experience of the lgbtq plus americans
in the military
during the 17 years that this pal policy
was in place
nearly 14 000 service members were
discharged for being gay
since the end of world war ii more than
100 thousand additional military members
were kicked out over their sexual
orientation
jan crawford spoke to members of the air
force to see how the culture has changed
when president bill clinton proposed
don't ask don't tell in 1993
he was trying to find compromise in a
fight over a ban on gays in the military
that had been in place
for centuries it is not a perfect
solution
it is not identical with some of my own
goals and it certainly will not please
everyone
perhaps not anyone clinton was right
the policy quickly sparked protests and
legal challenges
it really makes you be untruthful and
then that is something that
you know really confuses you and your
mind and in your heart about your
integrity that is always something that
will continuously eat at me
i mean i'm sure until the day that i die
and it forced service members like a
young
captain leah louderback to live what
amounted to a double life
all the you know nasty jokes that you
would hear and um i'm certain i would
take part in to make sure that you know
make sure that people knew i wasn't gay
at the time
you know those yeah horrible parts of
your of your past that you're not proud
of
but you really had no choice if you
wanted to continue to serve
i agree i don't know i don't know how
else i would have done it
for years louderbeck climbed the ranks
in the air force
lying to colleagues living in what she
describes as a constant state of
paranoia it was always a leap of faith
that you had to take to actually tell
somebody in the military because the
stakes were high
absolutely all they would have had to do
is say something to the commander
our people sacrifice a lot for their
country
including their lives none of them
should have to sacrifice their integrity
as well in 2010 president barack obama
repealed
don't ask don't tell
i remember just you know texting friends
and being on the phone and sending
emails and just
you know tears running down your face
just out of relief and happiness and
it's huge yes absolutely less than four
years later
lindsey johnson and shantae barber met
during training at the air force academy
and
soon began dating we felt we wanted to
keep our personal lives
close to our chest and every time you
would we would tell a friend
or family member or co-worker that we
felt comfortable enough
with i think it was a slow you know okay
here's here's another five pounds off
our chest
both women were ultimately outed at work
by coworkers
but said their fears turned out to be
unwarranted
even though initially it wasn't
on your terms when the story was
told you felt supported
i did feel supported yep my uh it kind
of everyone just
exceeded my expectations i just ended up
being super normal
which is really kind of all we want and
what anyone really wants
the couple got married in 2019 and for
them don't ask don't tell
feels like a distant memory it couldn't
fathom such a policy would be
in place because i don't see how it
really affects
serving our nation and being the best we
can when i get into the jet and i put my
helmet on
the airplane doesn't know if i'm a male
or a female
and that's what i want our society to
come to
they don't care if we're black or if
we're white or if we
are married to a woman or if we're
married to a male ladies and gentlemen
major general otterback spouse miss
brenda hall at the pentagon
louderback is now a two-star general in
charge of intelligence for the u.s space
force
diversity is essential to our future
success and security
she's using her position to lead a new
team tasked with recommending ways the
air force
and maybe the military as a whole can
become more inclusive
we need to look like the american public
and that american public has gay members
in it so even if we just recruit and we
recruit a diverse population
they won't stay if they don't feel
included and comfortable and part of the
team
in all aspects ladderback understands
that
more than anyone i always wanted to just
put on my desk i just wanted to be able
to put a picture
of my girlfriend and the fact that i
couldn't share any of that before but i
can share it now
it's a world of difference for cbs this
morning
jan crawford the pentagon
i love that story love lindsay and
shantae as a couple
thank you leah louderback you shouldn't
have to sacrifice your integrity
about how how the couple when they when
they finally became known how well they
were received
that's the best thing i agree 2021 20
we'll be right back
and it'll still be 2021 yeah